jeffrey tambor exits transparent after  sexual harassment allegations ET can  confirm the 73 year old actor will not  be returning to the hit Amazon series  this comes after facing two accusations  of sexual harassment by members of the  transparent team both claims he strongly  denies and calls quote utterly untrue  Jeffrey released a statement to ET on  Sunday that read in part playing more FF  Erma non-transparent has been one of the  greatest privileges and creative  experiences of my life  given the politicized atmosphere that  seems to have afflicted our set I don't  see how I can return all my life my  whole life I've been dressing up like a  man you spoke with Tambor in 2014 where  he opened up about being a part of the  show I was throw up nervous through the  filming of this because it's important  to me I was shaking like a leaf not  because I wanted to be good or want to  have good reviews but I wanted to do it  right